[Music]
this is Star Talk yielder grass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist I got
with me my co- Chuck Nice Chuck hey Neil
yeah you know we do a lot of topics but
uh I think there's a topic we don't give
enough attention to okay and that's the
search for Dark Skies on Earth as a city
person you know I grew up in New York
City the whole notion of a dark sky
didn't have many meaning because uh my
only dark sky was the local planetarium
the Hayden planetarium right so an
artificial dark sky but in a in a way
that's kind of cool they created a dark
sky just for you yes knowing I'd come
back a few decades later and serve as
director director there and you know
what and they're just like God that was
a good investment look at
that look how that worked out just to
show you that I'm not weirdly odd in
this way okay uh I'm not the only one
out there who loves Dark Skies let me
bring on my friend and colleague Matt
odow is a fellow astrophysicist a host
of PBS SpaceTime I want to ask you about
that uh associate professor of astronomy
and astrophysics at Leman college at
CUNY the City University of New York and
you're also an associate here at the
American Museum of Natural History how
you doing Matt I'm doing great Neil
thank you very much good to see you so
Matt I what what do Dark Skies mean to
you especially since they're not
Everywhere You Gotta like look for them
and find them yeah I I grew up in the
suburbs you know maybe not quite as
bright as New York City but uh I you
know I remember my first dark sky as a
kid you know I thought there are there
are so many stars you know in my little
Suburban neighborhood you know there's
at least a hundred that's right
you go to you know the Outback Australia
where it's pretty dry anyway um and you
look up and and you you can't even find
a spot of sky that doesn't have a star
wow spectacular I didn't see a dark sky
that matched what I saw in the
planetarium until I went deep into
Pennsylvania far I to cross New Jersey
you know cross the you say that like it
was like such a a a
treasury oh the drudgery I I actually
had to had to swim across the Hudson I
swam across the Hudson and then we got
into a conastoga wagon and made our way
to Pennsylvania across New Jersey so
Pennsylvania is rural and then I got to
see a night sky you know as nature had
intended it not even realizing that
that's just a sky in the Northeast where
there's humidity there's um some light
leakage on the horizon because even
hundreds of miles away you can see city
lights and so want you remind us what
the value of being in a desert is for
stargazing you know there there are two
big things right there's the fact that
deserts are big and so you're probably
far away from any Town people don't
build a lot of towns in the middle of
deserts uh I I was at a town in the
middle of the biggest desert in
Australia so Alice Springs which is in
the dead center Australia um recently
actually and uh I mean you just get a
little way out of town and look up and
um I don't remember seeing a sky like
that so you have the proximity to light
and as you say you want to be hundreds
of miles away okay in the middle of
Australia you're a thousand miles away
but then there's the dryness and the
dryness is key um so the water in the
atmosphere causes as um as the light
trickles down from the Stars it it sort
of bounces the light around on its way
down and so trickles it's moving at the
speed of light dude trickles trickles on
a cosmic scale on a cosmic scale crawl
it's eight minutes to get from the sun
it's like I can make it I can
trickles trickling but
okay but but it also bounces around so
when you look up at the stars in you
know somewhere where where there's some
humidity uh you you see these blurry
blobs okay so you so and you don't
really know you notice until you see the
sky from a desert or a dry Mountaintop
which is where we like to build our
observatories then there are these pin
Pricks these Crystal Clear pin Pricks um
and man it's it's stunning it's like at
the Hayden
planetarium yeah just like the
planetarium so many people don't think
of the water molecule as something that
matters in the night it just gives you
rain of course but all the best
observatories in the world are in
deserts for this reason yeah yeah you
don't want the water plus if you do have
water then it can make clouds and then
it can rain
and so deserts are good for there being
little rain which means there's very few
clouds typically yeah and you can
actually see fainter stars that way you
know the this the when the star gets
blurred out a little bit then what we
call the surface brightness goes down
and so so as long if you concentrate all
of that staright into a single point
your eye is going to be able to pick up
fainter far stars and further away I
forgot about that that's right because
if you smear out the light then it might
not be bright enough to trigger your
detection threshold exactly but
concentrate it all into one spot and
there it is a pin prick of light now in
the United States we have places that
can be far away from cities and you know
I think of the Mountain Time Zone of
course you know I mean definitely not
the West Coast or the East Coast Where
Have You Been what are some places
you've been
so let's see um I mean you know I've
seen some good stuff in New York uh also
but you know many many many but a little
bit blurry um but exactly as you had
West you know the middle of the country
um the Northeast is good but you know
again a bit of humidity but but you know
those Central States uh Nevada is
probably where I've done most of my
stargazing I would say really oh really
Nevada Nevada yeah of all places um
youve I mean a an amazing State you've
got Las Vegas you've got Reno cool
cities but pretty quick to get away from
them you know hop in a car um and oh I
get it so what what Nevada did was it
took all the city lights and put them
into just two cities pretty pretty much
pretty much they centralized they
centralized all the city lights whereas
the Northeast is just towns all the way
up you know it's crawling continual
Northeast Corridor okay so you put all
in one place then that leaves the rest
of the state because I was in Montana I
got a similar sense of that you know
they call that Big Sky country but what
good is a Big Sky if it's cloudy you
know it's not doesn't matter so
Montana's not in the desert uh latitudes
all right and
so if you go down south what's
interesting is that between 30 and 35
degrees north latitude okay is all the
great deserts of the northern hemisphere
so you get the Mojave Desert the GOI
desert the um the Sahara Desert oh the
and India would be a desert were it not
for the monsoon and India you know is
right on those parallels 30 to 35
degrees so so anyway so if you so if you
go into the United States Mountain time
zone so you're away from civilization
right and you get desert that pretty
much localizes where you can do this
right Matt yeah I mean it's the it's the
best of way you could do it absolutely
um you know people do good astronomy
everywhere because people are amazing
but but you know for me
Nevada Black Rock Desert in Nevada is my
favorite spot in a way it's it's uh it
it kind of balances because uh we can
see uh Las Vegas from space but in the
rest of the state you can see space from
there very clever perect balance that's
like a that's like a slogan or something
that's going to be on a bumper
sticker yeah so you get the benefit of
the desert so and which means also clear
skies and so so where did you observe
where precisely Matt so the Black Rock
Desert uh which is a few hours out of
Reno um is a an Alkali flat so it's this
huge many mile wide Alkali flat Ancient
Ancient lake bed
strange Place actually it's um you know
this this super basic uh uh dust on the
and very flat you can drive on this
surface okay most of the year you know
with your eyes closed there's nothing
for Miles um don't do that kids um and
and so when when the dust isn't up in a
a storm it is Crystal Clear um so I I've
I've been there a few times I've been
there with a a group a group of
colleagues who who run What's called the
Black Rock Observatory and they bring a
big telescope like a meter wide diameter
mirror telescope and but it's still
portable if they bring it it's portable
it's it's marginally portable yeah
marginally is yeah okay okay takes a
small van but yes yeah yeah okay okay so
now let me just ask this as a city
dweller myself
um when you're out there in the desert
is there a RIT Carlton
nearby just in case you I'm just saying
I mean if I want to spend the night yeah
there's a f there's a festar hotel right
in the Black Rock B he there course got
he got to know how to find it ask the
locals you're on a call with two
astrophysicists it's not you're not
spending the night anywhere you're
spending the day in the hotel Ah that's
right because the night is where the
action is baby the night is our we are
indeed creatur of the night take that
take that
Dracula we'll show you how to do it all
night
long oh look just another bumper sticker
astronomers do it all night long yeah I
know that we had that's an old one
that's an old one is that an old one oh
very old oh old cool okay yeah yeah yeah
so so Matt what were your favorite
targets of the night sky most of the
year you can see some some good deep Sky
objects and you know the the nebula uh
the most beautiful if you can see them
well okay so the the remnants of stars
that have ended their lives and blown
off their outer layers and so everyone's
seen these these crazy configurations of
colorful gas out there in space so with
a really good
telescope those are are gems um but um
you know the Andromeda galaxy is a
winner I think because it's so bright
you know you can actually see the
Andromeda galaxy with the naked eye at a
good dark sky dark sky sight W you know
it's it's plus plus it's a northern
hemisphere object you all object added
bonus it's uh it's two and a half
million light years away but you know if
you know how to look at it which is just
off where it actually is you see uh this
distant giant Galaxy just right there
but you're talking about averted Vision
can you explain that averted Vision
exactly right staring right at it it
sort of Fades out curious effect the one
the one thing that you can't go past the
if you want to wow um you know the
locals is Saturn showing people Saturn
through a telescope is the most mystical
experience for someone who hasn't
experienced you know all of this stuff
previously and Matt what impresses me is
you can show it to them through a
telescope and it's nowhere near as
richly displayed as a Hubble photo they
might see online yet this still blows
their mind yeah because you can can see
the Rings I See in photo I'm just I'm
just saying but there's something about
I I mean I I I know exactly what I
talking about because the two the first
two things I ever saw through a
telescope the first of course was the
moon okay and you get to see and you're
like oh my God like it's I'm right there
I'm on the moon I can't believe I'm on
the moon and the second was Saturn and
even though um when you look at like
Cassini and these images right where you
just see space probe to Saturn yeah
thank you uh and you see like how
detailed the Rings are and you can like
and they they almost look like this
little ballet of debris going around the
planet but you can't see it like that
through a telescope you you know it's it
looks like bright kind of blown out
version of that Cassini image but it's
so detailed in that it's actually so
different with the Rings and you can
make it out and it's like the only thing
that know in the sky like you know what
I mean like you've never looked up in
the sky before you know Saturn has rings
and then you're seeing it something
about that it's something confirming
evidence confir confirmatory evidence
that's it it's confirmatory evidence
it's like oh my God I'm really looking
out somehow all those Cassini movies or
h photos like you know we're so spoiled
on you know amazing CGI these days that
part of us maybe doesn't believe that
it's real but when the photons come from
Saturn directly through the telescope
and hit you in the eye then there's no
denying it because they sense of the
size of the universe yeah yeah so cool
so so Matt I hear that Nevada has a dark
sky Sanctuary what is
that I mean you know a dark sky
Sanctuary is a um a region where there's
regulation about the types of lights
that can be within a certain region
um you know so it's it's possible to do
Lighting in a way that doesn't destroy
the sky you know you don't have to shine
all your lights straight up how all of
your buildings down how Downy you're an
airplane and you fly need and you can
see a street light somebody's paying to
send light to your eyeball in the
airplane yeah right right okay so what's
what do you you know it looks bleak
everything I've read about the future of
Dark Skies yeah so it seems like these
are these are cherished places few
places left on
Earth yeah so the expansion of the
Cities more and more towns in between
cities until you have the whole country
maybe the world being the Northeast
Corridor uh and there are some spots
that presumably will never become cities
you know there the spots in nada I doubt
the Black Rock Desert will become a city
but these places become more and more
distant to most people and so fewer and
few fewer people you know have access
and kids growing up are less and less
likely to see more than a 100 stars in
the sky to your point earlier that
people are growing up without any
relationship to the night sky they don't
even know to look up and be curious
about it I think we will lose something
deeply if that's the world if that's the
Next Generation that's going to lead the
world they'll have no sense of the the
paths of curios I it that led us into
the universe yeah I mean it's hard to
know how important it was or how lucky
we are that we have a transparent
atmosphere I mean you know obviously
it's good that it's transparent that we
that we can see but it's transparent all
the way to space we can imagine
situations where you have this permanent
cloud cover at some level and we
wouldn't even know that the Universe
existed beyond our I think about that
all the time oh really all the time if
we grew up on the surface of Venus which
has a very thick cloud cover now Venus
doesn't happen to have a moon but if it
did we would have we would just look at
the tides come in and out mysteriously
right have no understanding of it we
have no idea that there was a night sky
with stars and nebula in the Andromeda
galaxy there'd be no cosmology until
someone ascended through the air and
emerged on the top of the clouds and
imagine the first but would we even get
there how instrumental was the night sky
in sparking that
Curiosity F to fly in the first place
yeah so that's a very good point mat I
had not considered that the Curiosity
stimulators are looking to a place that
you otherwise cannot reach and asking
yourself how can I how will I ever reach
it well then again somebody would have
looked up and said I wonder what's
beyond those puffy things up there I
wonder what's behind that that canopy
that's above us you yeah not everybody
but some some D they take it a bit
longer but you know
in fact in the latest Stark talk book we
devote chapters and chapters to that
kind of state of mind you know what is
beyond it's titled to infinity and
beyond and the infinity is a moving
Target in the 1700s if I say go to the
moon say that's not possible so the Moon
is at Infinity to you for all your for
all you know right you can't ever get
there well plus you need new laws of
physics and this mythical magical
substance called Rocket Fuel and a
rocket on top of that then you can get
to the moon but but that's completely
mythical at that stage so yeah I'm
intrigued by this so Matt just describe
your emotions when you're out under the
night sky now as a professional
astrophysicist if you were not an
amateur astronomer but now as a
professional astrophysicist what
emotions come over you you know some
people have asked whether understanding
the universe too well takes away the
magic uh the opposite it it expands
and uh
amplifies all of the experience so I now
now when I go out under the night sky I
mean my first impulse is the same
childlike holy crap look at all those
stars but now I have I guess the
apparatus to be able to imagine this
vast three-dimensional universe and the
distance between the stars and me on on
this spinning orb of rock and all of
this stuff so I can I can sort of hold
that model to the stars and um yeah it's
a good man it's it's a good
trip that sounds so cool yeah I still
well up when I when I go to mountain
tops and I look up to the night sky if
I'm alone and just the Eerie Silence of
just me the mountain side and the night
sky well Matt it's been a delight to
have you and remind me what uh what kind
of stuff you do on PBS's SpaceTime oh
sure we do astrophysics astronomy and
and physics and we go we go pretty hard
in a lot of areas you know we're doing
uh a bunch of quantum mechanics episodes
right now so you know there anything
Weir a real learning experience yeah
yeah people learn all right come and
check it out okay do that our next guest
is a National Geographic Explorer
astrophotographer and science photo
Journal journalist meet BC to
freshy hey Star Talk fans I wanted to
take a quick moment to thank our
partners at Travel nevada.com you know
with this week's partial eclipse and the
total eclipse happening in early 2024
we're quickly reminded of how important
it is to get outside and to look up but
if you're in a big city like I am you
know that it is near impossible to fully
appreciate all that the night sky has to
offer so as home to more of the last
true Dark Skies than anywhere in the
lower 48 states we want to encourage you
to consider Nevada when booking your
next Cosmic Adventure want to go on a
guided tour through the Stars led by
dark sky rangers will Journey to the
Great Basin and book a spot on the star
train as one of 17 International dark
sky sanctuaries worldwide you can also
visit the masacre rim Wilderness study
area scary name great place to look up
look I put that telescope of yours to
good use well check out the
constellations from the tonopa
stargazing Park and a quick tip from us
to you these places are remote so if
you're traveling there be sure to bring
a map because your cell phone might not
work and yes I am talking about a
physical map the kind that you unfold
and then you can never fold back the way
you have unfolded it all right as always
we hear at Star Talk in encourage you to
keep looking up and to get out there by
visiting travel nevada.com that's travel
nevada.com for your next night sky
adventure this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
with my co-host Chuck Nice Chuck yes
Neil what's happening we've got with us
right in the house babak tough fresh did
I say that right B back B perfect
perfect you are an astrophotographer a
space
photojournalist which sounds like you go
to space to get pictures but that's
probably not what it is but that's what
it sounds like Paparazzi Man Cosmo
Paparazzi yeah let's get a closeup on
that Lander right uh soari over here
over here opposite
T smile this who are you wearing who are
you
wearing you're National Geographic
Explorer this is a highly uh privileged
coveted designation that goes to people
who are scattered around the world doing
their thing in the National Geographic
family of uh people bringing the
universe to the rest of us you're also
an amateur astronomer and we're going to
find out why that is a badge of honor
and not a denigration uh you studied
physics in school love that and you're
an advocate for night skies dark skies
and that's another good thing and plus
you're a founder of the world at night
initiative we we'll get into that when
we uh get back to that and uh so let's
let's let's tell me what you're about B
back what what what drives you what
where what how did it all began and
what's your relationship with your
mother let's get into this very deep
let's really get into
it well I'm originally from Iran from
Teran I'm Iranian American Science
journalist and photographer uh my
interest to astronomy started with the
first look at the Moon like many others
at the age of 13 I borrowed this
telescope on top of a roof in apartment
in Teran which is highly light polluted
uh had a look at the moment I couldn't
believe my eyes you know it was much
more than the map I had in my hand all
the craters mountains and this was just
a tiny telescope 2 in you know all I can
remember that scene is still second by
second was almost like being the Appo
Orbiter going around the Moon because I
had no tracking with the telescope so it
was with the earth rotation the the
scene was moving across Across The View
and I thought you know that would be
cool to capture it on film so that was
the next night wa wait just to be clear
you said something thing that I want to
make sure our audience fully understands
you have a telescope that's not plugged
in it just points in One Direction and
the Moon is in the frame but because
Earth is
rotating the what's in the frame is
passing by and the magnification of the
telescope is such that you're basically
observing the rotation of the earth as
the sky goes by your your field of view
anytime you look through a telescope
that happens anytime you even take a
picture of the sky even your phone if
you go beyond 30 seconds you start to
see stars are not pinpoint anymore or
little Trails this is a fact for the
earth rotation I mean it's a very easy
evidence of how Earth is rotating and
how the sky is turning above us that
sounds kind of annoying like it would
ruin every picture that's very true
that's very
true that's why we are limited with
shorter exposures less than 30 seconds
unless you use a divice that tracks with
the earth rotation that can freeze the
earth rotation we call it the star
tracker or use a motor motor attached to
your telescope that can track the Stars
I didn't have that that tiny telescope
so that why that's why the view was
moving and it felt like being in an
orbit around the moon so later on I
became an editor at astronomy magazine
of Iran I started the TV program for
about 10 years we had a weekly TV
program on a space on astronomy I was
highly inspired by Neil in fact I
emailed you back in '90s if you can
remember I'm not sure oh my gosh did I
reply yeah I you did you
did well that's good yeah if if you
didn't this would be very awkward right
now it would be an awkward moment
completely I I do reply to all emails
eventually so the eventually
is I'm glad to know that I reping to me
okay um yes I was very inspired by Carl
Sean at the time until you know when he
passed away I wrote one of my first
articles for astronom magazine about
Carl San and later um I started a
program called the war at night in 2007
I was still based in Iran and since the
program became more and more Global with
exhibitions here and there I had to
leave Iran because it was not possible
with all the limitations from the
government and also the sanctions and
internet filter a so me and my wife
decided to leave to Germany and later on
to the US I became a National Geographic
photographer in
2012 and recently much more involved
with naio across the platform with the
society and other parts of um the
platform of National Geographic and just
to remind people in this moment the
National Geographic platform is huge we
just published our third book in
collaboration with National Geographic
books just came out like a week ago and
so naio does a lot of different things
uh for this world or for our
appreciation of the world so we're I
guess we're in the family with you as
well so I just have to slip that in
there okay yeah so in 2007 when the word
at night started I I shifted from
science journalism more into photography
but still in today photography I try to
bring in my science journalism passion
into my visual storytelling so every
image to me has um has a title has you
know a subtitle and all the elements of
an
article um recently I started to work on
a project for National Geographic
society called life at night which
brings the attention more to the ground
still at nighttime and how animals are
in relationship with natural night
environment how dark skies is important
not only to Star gazes like us but also
to billions of animals who are not
jurnal right and how light pollution is
impacting that relationship nobody gives
them a thought at all oh my God nobody
does uh you know um you look at casinos
and casinos are extremely bright beyond
beyond what they should be and uh uh
you'll find that the indigenous bird
population wherever there are casinos is
totally screwed up it's because the
birds think it's daytime 24 hours a day
yeah more than 80% of birds in North
America which are migratory they travel
at night they fly at night because it's
safer to fly at night there's no
predator and it's also less much more
energy efficient without the Heat and
because of um night flying they use
stars for Celestial navigation as well
as Earth magnetic field and the
landmarks but light pollution is a new
source of attraction to them and
completely disrupt their navigation
system so they come down to the source
of light right and most of them
unfortunately died either by losing the
time either impacting or getting lost in
the cities wow well so Chuck when you
said casinos you mean the illumination
of the casino on the exterior when you
said they're bright okay yeah yeah
because you'll often find casinos in an
isolated place you know so think about
it you know like all of Las Vegas right
well yeah it's in a desert or Atlantic
City it's on the beach or you know Las
Vegas is visible from it's visible from
Saturn yeah right yeah
exactly so you know but yeah we did a
project in fact about the light of Los
Angeles and Las Vegas and the darkest
Sky of Death Valley um within the border
of Nevada and California which is a
darkest sky place it's a designated
International dark of Sky Park and Las
Vegas was boldly visible almost like
Sunrise from 90 miles away then we went
to 150 miles away was is still visible I
even have a record from 220 miles away
and there is still a glow so this is
well beyond the distance to your horizon
so it's not a matter of sight lines to
the lights right it's the glow in the
air that it puts up that you can still
see because your horizon is what maybe
20 miles away from wherever wherever you
happen to actual Horizon maybe 30 miles
yes that's the actual Horizon yeah so
there's some refraction impact too
because of the refraction we see a
further away Horizon M but that's
certainly called a sky glow it's um it's
a reflection of light from dust from
aerosol from clouds in the sky and the
lower the place is the more Dusty it is
the more cyle it generates of course
right and which makes mountaintops a
good Target for doing observing even
close to the cities it's very
interesting when you look at the light
pollution Maps looking for darkest Sky
places near you the elevation is not
there that factor is not visible in the
light pollution maps and if you for
example give you an example in Los
Angeles if you go to Mount Wilson
Observatory which is within the edge of
the Los Angeles you can see the Milky
Way from Los Angeles with all that
light Fair barely visible but still you
can see the Milky Way it's just like an
Impossible Dream to see um you know 180
degrees of light of Los Angeles and the
Milky Way is visible because it's 6,000
fet above the city H I just have to add
that Mount Wilson is where Edwin
Hubble discovered that galaxies are
whole other that fuzzy objects in the
night sky are other galaxies and he
discovered the expanding Universe all of
that in the 1920s so we are in the
Centennial Celebration of these
discoveries not only that quantum
physics was formulated in the 1920s as
well all at Mount Wilson Observatory so
that's in fact 100 years the 100 years
anniversary of discovery of expansion of
universe it's coming in
October wow okay I'm gonna put that on
my
calendar break out break out some
champagne so you said that Death Valley
in Nevada on the border of uh California
was a dark skies site is that like a
sanctuary or what does it mean to be a
dark skies
site uh I work in Partnership sometimes
with a nonprofit called International
dark sky Association and or dark ski.org
is where they put all the resources they
have and they have designated more than
200 sites worldwide in more than 20
countries in fact uh one of them is in
Nevada and these places are um dark
enough to see the Milky Way some of them
are known as sanctuaries as you
mentioned these are the top level the
darkest some of the best observatories
in the world for example um Mount AA or
observatories in Chile there are in such
places where the Milky Ways still looks
like from the down of humankind you can
see it without any impact of light
pollution we still have those places
then comes the darkest Sky Parks there's
some light glows on the horizon but it's
still it's beautiful like many of the
Southwest Parks um is included in the
darkest Sky part AR designation we have
also darkest Sky communities where
people are trying to change lights to
make the area more sky friendly less
light polluted and these are different
designations and there's also another
program by UNESCO which has Starlight
reserves yeah i' would be surprised if
UNESCO didn't get a get a get part of
its interest in there because that's uh
they've been we their their scope is
open from just cultural sites to places
that or where you have a special
relationship with nature and the world
itself true I have a fast uh
International dark sky Association story
where they got ganga on me that Chuck
did I ever tell you that no okay when we
opened the rose Center for Earth and
space in the year 2000 in the middle of
Manhattan on Manhattan's Upper West Side
we had these tiny little pen lights in
the in the plaza area before you enter
the building and these tiny little 10
watt lights were pointing
upwards and I got a letter in the mail
from the dark sky Association that said
you need to be an example for the rest
of them and not have upward pointing
lights these were tiny little pin lights
in the pavement and I thought that was
gangster that in in manhatt right in
Manhattan oh my gosh yeah I had to
simultaneously love him and say what the
are you doing yeah I was gonna say that
it's a little nitpicky that's a little
little nitpicky you know yeah but I but
I definitely appreciated their sentiment
so uh B back you describe the world
night initiative as combining art and
culture um you mentioned nocturnal
animals but in what way is art and
culture mixed in with
this well if you look at the images we
take of the night of Sky they're not
necessarily scientific we have two kinds
of astrophotography one made with
telescopes deeper Sky Photography in
general it's called and the other one is
more called night Escape photography
which includes Earth and Sky they're
mainly wide angle in a wide angle image
that resemble the field of view of human
eye you are not going to discover a
Galaxy you're not going to discover a
new Comet you're aiming for art and
you're aiming for science communication
that's where um the art of
astrophotography can be a platform to
tell people about the importance of
night to Sky principles of practical
astronomy and also the issue of light
pollution so you're talking about these
pictures where someone is standing there
with their arms up you see the Milky Way
in the background there's a
mountainscape and trees and it's just a
beautiful photo that includes the night
sky that's what you're talking about
right that's right sometimes there's a
story involved I I try to include four
factors in my photog photography and
highly recommend to any viewer who's
going to be an astrophotographer to have
this in mind art technique these are
very obvious for photography as a basis
then comes the moment could be a meure
comet a wild animal at night and a story
when these four come together you have
an image that can create an impact can
keep in memory uh of somebody who's
viewing it i' love that i' love
this is this
is time
honored process right this is oh my gosh
because when you say it's just a picture
of it's a cosmic object I can tell the
story of the cosmic object but I can't
bring it back to you I can't make it
real I can't make a story that you then
share with your next of kin right so
this how important this is through the
history of civilization oh my gosh yeah
it's very important to make it realistic
like to emphasize on that too because
today astrophotography could be
generally based on composite images
stacking different exposures and putting
them together in Photoshop but it's
important to um to consider that the
elements of the sky are like the
elements of the natural world you cannot
copy a mountain on top of a lake where
it doesn't exist unless it's for an
artistic Reason Not in documentary
photography and for the same reason you
cannot copy the Moon from another part
of the sky to wherever you like this is
like to me it's like cheetah on top of a
lie is what it is point you're just
lying people do that all the time people
especially the moon and you know it
because the they don't typically when
they do that they don't know that people
in the know know what the orientation of
the Moon needs to be to the Horizon
depending on your latitude on Earth and
they'll just slap a moon there sometimes
it's upside down sometimes it's
backwards sometimes the the cues where
you can just get it wrong and I I'll
call them out I'll be up in face when I
they don't they don't do it around Neil
okay let let's come onen let me let's be
let me tell you something this dude went
on the Today show was just like hey uh
you know that Globe thing you got going
in the beginning it's wrong it's totally
wrong no no The Daily Show that was The
Daily Show The Daily Show that's
spinning backwards it was spinning
backwards yeah yeah yeah I let you that
was the beginning of the uh interview
stop so I I love your message one people
one sky and that's very hopeful very uh
peace orienting thought there so how do
we get people before we uh continue to
get out and do more to look up I mean
Neil's always saying keep look keep
looking up how about the people who
aren't looking up at all to they not
keep looking up how do they start
looking up I think a trip to a national
park or State Park in the darkest sky
place um is the best way to do this
because many of the national parks in
the US and Canada are dark sky
designated locations especially in the
southwest us some of my favorites for
example in Arizona and Nevada border is
the Western end of uh Grand Canyon um or
the Great Basin National Park it's at
high altitude in thead and it's also
very dark uh there are plenty of darkest
Sky location in that area all the five
major national parks in Utah darkest Sky
designated or going to be soon in North
Western Nevada we have the Black Rock
Desert another dark sky place even very
close to Las Vegas on the way to Bey on
the way to Death Valley there's the
darkest Sky area another place I have
photographed many times it's cathedral
gge which is inside Nevada and the
border of Utah and it's just fascinating
um rock formations with the darkest guy
above it is there a map they can go to
online that identifies these dark spots
there are two ways to do that one is um
light pollution map. info uh that's a
website and there is also a layer for
Google Earth um a University study
provided this layer of um known as the
um the map the atlas of artificial Sky
glow um and this you can add it to your
Google Earth and then you can zoom in
See Another Place Another website is
blue-m marble. De it's a German
Enthusiast who include all these
satellite images from every year you can
look at bird at night and find darker
Sky places near you but do not forget
that elevation is not there so if you
even if you're in a bright area but you
find an elevated site which is at least
4,000 5,000 ft above sea level then you
start to see darkest Sky even within the
cities gotcha m interesting very cool
and right now you are speaking to us
from Iceland what are you doing there
today from rovic Iceland this was my
last day after two weeks of a photo
Workshop capturing the northern lights
and the Milky Way with a group coming
from all around the country I do this um
all around the world I do this twice a
year in March and September known as
Aurora Photo Tours oh wow so people can
actually hang out with you and learn how
to do what you're doing is oh look at
that yeah I do four or five workshops
yeah my invitation might still be in my
inbox I'm guessing
exactly anytime now I'll check let me
check my inbox if I've ever been invited
on
this so you made a career of this this
is I this is a a brilliant um important
and
envious career path that you've made for
yourself here congratulations on that
thank you and uh keep that going and by
back thanks again for being our guest on
Star
Talk we've got next up Bradley Mills
Bradley Mills you are Nevada park ranger
our very first park ranger on welcome
welcome thank you very much thanks for
having me yeah you guys are all cool
with your outfits and you got your hat
you got that parer do you wear the park
ranger hat the flat smar hat like the
Smokey Bear thank you Neil the Smokey
Bear hat abolutely
it's just do me a favor please just go
hey boo boo
no so you are the lead astronomy Ranger
and I'm so delighted to even know that
such a person
exists and awesome yeah and so as as a
park ranger leading the astronomy effort
what what are your tasks well uh so
great Bas and National Park where where
I work we have one of the most extensive
uh astronomy program kind of sets of
probably any national park in the nation
um so I just get to to lead uh
essentially how we how we run it all um
and oversee I've got a seasonal staff of
about five Parker Rangers who get to
focus solely on astronomy every single
year so I get to to work doing that
which is just an absolute delight and
let me just back up just for a moment I
this park is a national park in Nevada
it's not a state park in Nevada correct
that's correct we we're the only
National Park entirely within Nevada so
there are some other small smaller
National Park units but we're the only
one that has you know got that full
special name and where where exactly are
you because I'm I'm telling you right
now all of this talk about Nevada and
the Dark Skies is giving me a reason to
go to Nevada because I've only been to
Las Vegas and Las Vegas not it does not
have Dark Skies it does not absolutely
not and it reminds me of work so I would
love another reason to go to Nevada how
close are you to Las Vegas or how easy
are you to get to I should say we're one
of the more difficult places to reach uh
there's no public transportation there's
only a couple highways that even come
anywhere near us uh so we're about five
hours north of Las Vegas and we are I
mean way out in the middle of nowhere
and that's that's the benefit because if
we were anywhere anywhere near Vegas
it's the brightest spot on earth
we got to get far far away so we're
luckily about 5 hours North it's a it's
a Bradley if you don't want me to come
just say don't come you don't
have no we we love it we're just we're
one of the least visited it's so hard
for people to get out here you know we
get change that right now let's do it
try to change that yeah so so you manag
the Great Basin Observatory what is that
because just to be clear when geologists
use the word Observatory there it's just
a place where they go stand and look
around right so when astronomer says
Observatory we got real Hardware there
to connect you to the universe typically
so which kind of Observatory is
this I just love that you're dissing
geologist don't call it Observatory just
standing there looking at an scar that's
not an observatory that's just that's
that's a Scenic what do you call Scenic
Overlook Scenic Overlook exactly well so
so luckily I am not the one fully in
charge of the Great Basin Observatory
we've got it was built by our uh great
by the Great Basin National Park
Foundation uh entirely from donated
funds which is incredible um but it's a
proper research Observatory it's got the
Dome it's got a 70 cimeter telescope it
is a it's the real deal uh and I think
it's might even be one of the largest in
Nevada could only find information on
one other research grade observatory in
the state so we're we're pretty special
having that out here and uh it's it's a
lot of fun so what's the what's the
elevation at the Great Basin Observatory
so uh The Observatory is right around 68
6900 feet um so it's oh my gosh yeah
it's high up yeah our Park starts it
like pretty much no lower than 6,000 and
goes all the way up to the highest or
well second highest point in Nevada uh
at Wheeler Peak at 13,063 feet so it's
and what at what point do you
hallucinate from from lack of oxygen you
we have people suffering from altitudes
sickness even this low so I'm sure
that's it doesn't take you you know to
get that high to have that happen yeah
you know my favorite thing to observe is
what happens to unopened bags of potato
chips that you bring to high altitude
they get really really puffy and exact I
just I love these secondary experiments
you can do at at high altitude so what
is this we heard here about a star train
what is that so the uh Nevada Northern
Railway is a Historic Railway line that
operates out of elely Nevada and they uh
run a train have been running this train
uh for 10 years in partnership with the
park uh that goes from elely Nevada
about uh 15 20 miles north of town and
uh to a telescope Flats where we've got
telescope set up and let people kind of
hop off the train they get to look
through telescopes we do Ranger programs
and trivia and astronomy just fun things
you know give out prizes and stuff on
the train uh and we get to ride back uh
in the middle of the night Chuck this
doesn't this sound like a set up for one
of the scenes in Westworld where you
take some some little some little train
to go out into the desert and all of a
sudden right exactly there's Aon there
and a gun fighter ready to and all of a
sudden Ed Harris shows up and you're
just like wait a minute wait a
minute it does kind of sound like that
so uh it sorry I interrupted the train
goes from where to where uh so it goes
from El Nevada up the step Valley so it
actually doesn't come into the park but
it's uh it's still in the Great Basin
which is about the size of Nevada so
it's a very similar environment and we
still get some excellent excellent night
skies out there so you said you need
that you have a telescope set up what do
I need to bring here I am a person I'm
just like okay why not let's go
stargazing I'll give it a try what do I
need to bring if you're coming to the
park in one of our programs just
yourself and a a sense of enthusiasm
that's all you need because we got all
the other equipment we've got all the
knowledge and we'd love to share it so
it makes it really easy for for people
to come and experience the night's guy
wow yeah the amount of times I have
people who have come out here never
seeing the Milky Way sometimes never
even seeing more than five six stars in
this guy and then get that was me
growing up yes count me among those me
too I I grew up in San Diego County and
it you know I counted maybe 10 stars in
a planet every once in a while and then
come out here and every night in the
summer even sometimes when there's a lot
of moon you get to see the Milky Way
it's it's incredible it's lifechanging
do you ever do you ever play um audio of
Neil degrass Tyson so that people feel
like they're looking up at a
planetarium we what we let him know we
poked lots
of so many
stars exactly it's just a dome it's just
exact so generally the best obser in
sites in the world are in deserts so
just to remind me of my geography is all
of Nevada count as a desert essentially
uh big big big sections of it so we're
in the Great Basin Desert out here and
so you know we get very very little
annual rainfall we are incredibly high
up so we got the high elevation you know
we're High Desert dry it really really
adds to making this such an excellent
place for for stargazing right because
the drier it is the the fewer air
molecules are in the air to disrupt the
the the the Starlight and fewer clouds
and less rain and so everything work so
exactly so you pretty much guaranteed a
clear night anytime you schedule this
isn't that right no not necessarily we
have a pretty intense monsoon season
through through July and August and we
get get programs rained out every once
in a while but if it's just cloudy we
can always find something in the clouds
it's it's still dark enough here that
even if you only have you know that much
in the sky you can still find you know a
nebul Galaxy or something in there to be
able to show people okay when you say
cloudy you don't mean overcast you mean
clouds in the sky right looking between
clouds got yeah yeah exactly can you
quantify how dark the sky is I mean is
there ways to know who qualifies and who
doesn't so so we measure luminance here
using I actually even grabbed it uh we
have a little Sky quality meter that we
go around uh once a month it's like a
like a camera light meter pretty much we
point it at the sky a triar it's like
it's a sky
triar oh I should have said that yeah
yeah I got you I beat you to it hold it
up to the sky
go okay she's dead Jim okay it's cloudy
Jim that's great yeah so you know I just
pointed in my office it's just said 8.5
which means it's bright in daytime but
it can go up to 22 is is where we we
want to kind of hang out at and great
basin's right around like 21.6 21.8
which means we have some the darkest
Skies that are are measured in this
country so the bigger the number the
darker the sky the darker that's correct
just in case that was not clear okay
absolutely got it when we think of
national parks and national forests for
example there's a maintenance budget for
it you know for for hiking paths perhaps
or fire management tasks that they go
through for for the astronomy club
Nevada what what kind of management is
necessary there other than maybe just
the upkeep of the telescope that's a big
part of it is just maintaining our
equipment um but I get a new I like to
kind of say I got a fresh crop of
Rangers every year so they we got some
people that return and otherwise I've
got new folks who we got to train up and
got to get them uh learning more about
the sky if they're still you know just
kind of feeling the amateur level and
wanting to get to that point where they
can really really teach people but
otherwise it's pretty simple and it's
just managing uh just managing the
people and we also get a lot of
volunteers here throughout the year for
some of our big festivals and other
things that we do so there's a lot of
lot of work put into that as well if
you're an AM amateur astronomer it's a
really great thing to get out to you
because you can get paid for being an
amateur astronomer that's right that's
right which would that make you a
professional Astron I guess
so oh all I'm saying is you got you got
a nice shiny badge there I'm telling you
if I came out there I would say I don't
need no stinking
[Music]
badges I don't need no stinking know
this gu so so do you have to go through
uh like brush up classes or something
you know to just stay on top of the
constellations and the latest
discoveries that you might then add to
the stuff you point out like how do you
stay current well so it's just a lot of
uh just doing research and you know when
you have downtime or if a program gets
canceled means we get to spend more time
learning so we read a lot of
Publications we're always keeping an eye
on what's going to be above us in the
sky that night obviously you know so we
can point out things like uh cool space
missions that might be happening we got
to see some uh rocket boosters recently
we were just even talking to people
about the Osiris mission that uh just
landed last week so it's been a we get a
lot of very very cool things that happen
near us uh that are very visible that
you wouldn't really necessarily be able
to see if you I'm very glad to hear that
because the universe is not just the
stars as they're laid out for us on
Earth there's this whole Frontier of
research unfolding that does make
headlines right it's not even obscure
you know with the Osiris Rex Mission it
was a piece of an asteroid brought back
to Earth which an adjacent Landing in an
adjacent state right right there in Utah
so okay well this delight to meet you
Bradley and I'm I'm even more delighted
to know that someone such as you exists
in this country or even in the world
who's tasked with bringing the night sky
to the public and preserving the night
sky in the interest of civilization
there's hope for us yet there I think
so all right so Bradley give us a
parting sentence give us a parting
sentence to take us out if you ever get
the chance come out to Nevada broaden
your horizons see the night sky as it
naturally should be all right okay so
I'll summarize that say and say keep
looking up
there you
go all right we're out of here thank
thanks Bradley always good to have you
chat always a pleasure this has been a
stargazing edition of Star Talk Neil
degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist as always you to keep
looking
[Music]
up